bonsoir échange standard nous emmène
cette semaine à dijon à la rencontre de
deux femmes qui ont la même passion
l'esthétique mais elles n'ont pas la
même profession toutes les deux elles
utilisent un pinceau l'une sur des
modèles la seconde sur des gâteaux quand
une cac designer et une maquilleuse
professionnelle échangent leur métier
vous allez voir ce que ça va donner
son appel destiné à changer de vie
qu'est-ce qu'ils adhèrent à dijon on
commence c'est parti allez c'est parti
j'ai déjà préparé un petit gâteau donc
la base le biscuit ouvrages et cetera
donc là maintenant il va falloir que tu
puisse réaliser un glaçage parfait avec
une à base de ganache tu vas s'en tire
toi même très bien
c'est de tourner le plateau le tourner
et adon bras voilà que tourner le
plateau tout nu plateau vous fait alors
l'excédent dans l'autre amour travail
est ce que tu as déjà travaillé avec la
pâte à sucre vraiment y découvre cette
année mais reste qu'à ta fais des petits
cochons nazis jeu juste udine où les tu
peux refaire une boule comme tout à
l'heure j'ai c'est wendy c'est peut-être
un petit peu plus manuels et physique
que le métier de matthews qui m'a posé
un petit peu de difficultés ces oueds
pétrir la pâte et voilà et puis vraiment
de poser la patte sur le gâteau sans que
ça fasse de plis éviter blue d'air ça
soit vraiment parfait
est ce que tu veux continuer au mettre
en boule un parce par couleur
si tu veux c'est effet de galles à tout
moment peut-être une petite fleur à
poser sur le web je veux tu en voilà
[Musique]
c'était les 15 elle explique bien elles
laissent pas beaucoup faire mais elles
expliquent bien elle est à l'écouté et
la contrée très vite elle mange le
trouve parfait le gâteau il est super
beau voilà ce gâteau est offert un toit
du par avec eva cool mais voilà avant de
manger on va changer vous êtes prête
louis le signe indien maquilleuse oui
[Musique]
bienvenue dans un studio de photographie
avec lequel je travaille régulièrement
on va faire un teint voilà un maquillage
vraiment ce qu'on va appeler de mise en
beauté
donc tu prends le pinceau tu vas faire
des petites touches un petit peu partout
et puis après tu vas l'étaler en faisant
des petits ronds en fait à être
transparent donc faut que tu saches toit
s'était bien passé tu commences par une
couleur claire et tu poudre toute la
paupière mobile et vu que tu m'as qui
quelqu'un d'autre et patois faut pas
soufflé sur les pinceaux ça a beaucoup
qui font fou on a déjà quand et
mafieuses tu restes sur le côté de
position contre ses positions en fait en
gros tu dois être en fente pour pas de
casser le dos et tu dois pouvoir voilà
tu te déplaces d'avant en arrière mais
tu penses jamais dont ils vont les
lumières on sait jamais si on fait mal
ou enfin comment comment il ya quand
même un contact et on est très proches
donc
je pense que pour moi en tout cas c'est
ça le côté très très difficile de ce
métier tu vas faire toutes les lignes
montante
tu prends ta matière et tu remplis sans
déborder sinon je serai puni d'accord
est ce qu'il ya un risque quand même
pour appliquer enfin dans cette année de
faire des petits tizac où je t'arrête
c'était qui voudraient très belle
expérience
surtout que c'est la première fois que
je vois comment maquiller quelqu'un il
faut s'entraîner un prêt chez pas en
terme de temps mais elle apprend quand
même assez vite je mérite et je vais
jamais prendre la place de claire
[Musique]
mesdames l'expérience est terminée
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu qu'on soit
une photo souvenir lui aller 3 2 1
[Musique]